well it's now at eighty-four days since
the government closed schools to all but
the most vulnerable children and those
of key workers primary schools took
pupils from reception that year one and
year six back at the start of June years
ten and twelve can go back from Monday
although only a quarter of each year
will be allowed in at a time nearly nine
million children would usually be in
school but the latest figures showed
just six hundred and fifty thousand were
on the 4th of June well to discuss the
impact of this with us join now by the
Chief Inspector of Ofsted and mandus
film and thank you very much for coming
on the program today and there are
reports that primary schools will be
told they can reopen fully before the
summer if they can keep class sizes
below fifteen is that realistic I think
a lot of schools are doing really
creative things to to help manage their
class sizes and that there are schools
that are offering rotor's there is there
are schools that schools that are
bringing children in one one week on one
week off there are all sorts of ways
that people are making this work we're
just relaxing the social distancing
rules from two meters to warn me to help
more schools be able to offer full
education to more pupils so if you I've
got a very strange delay on the line
which is making this difficult the
there's a hierarchy of infection control
measures and that's been explained to us
very clearly by the public health
advisors starting with hand-washing and
working working down through bubbles and
social distancing social distancing
within the bubbles the half size classes
is according to the guidance and
aspiration not an absolute requirement
so what's really important is is that
everybody works to the guidance as it
stands plans for the relaxations that
are likely to come along in future yes
obviously a reduce a reduced distance
expectation will flow through a flow
flow through into greater capacity in
schools but what we need to get to is
that plan for how we build capacity over
time and use relaxation as that as they
come through but concentrate on the main
objective which should surely be to get
as many children back into school as
possible and as soon as possible because
they are losing so much now through
losing education losing the wider social
interaction losing loosely using the
wider development and of course losing
their preparedness for the economic
opportunities of the future I know it's
something you've spoken out very
strongly consistently throughout the
pandemic are you concerned that without
more money without a bigger national
effort without more support teachers and
schools that some schools might not even
be able to fully reopen in September
well I think what we've seen shows how
important it is to have the delay is
happening again I think what we've seen
shows how important it is to have
planning the ticket planning that
everybody takes part in and takes part
in constructively and what we've seen I
think in the last few weeks has been has
been what happens when you've got for
example schools and groups of teachers
involved but other voices other factors
perhaps coming in too complicated to
enter frustrate them in their efforts to
get things open we've we've got we've
got a complicated position here and
closing a school is easy you just you
just say it's going to close reopening
it involves staff it involves school
leaders it involves cancels it involves
sometimes groups multi-academy trust
involve central government in court it
involves parents everybody in that list
has to be working together
constructively I'm wanting to get to get
schools open again or just one one
faction within that and it can help slow
things write down or construct can stop
them happening when they otherwise would
I think you have a persevering with our
own social distancing in these
interviews brings its own challenges
when it comes to the technology as well
but you are still definitely making your
points very clearly we've seen thousands
of people taking to the streets in
recent weeks protesting about inequality
in our society and of course one of the
strongest weapons in our Arsenal against
that inequality is education are you
really worried about what could happen
to a generation really of young people
who could be spending months and months
out of the classroom boredom and
frustration which most of our teenagers
are experiencing the moment is clearly
not helpful and I'd love to have them in
school at the moment studying history
getting that wider Kahn
I'm getting more time learning about
historical topics like the civil rights
movement in America the slave trade the
British Empire all of which are things
which the vast majority of schools do
normally teach we've got children who
aren't getting that context aren't
getting the opportunity to discuss them
in school through citizenship lessons
through all all the ways in which we go
about preparing young people to take
their place in society but the vast
majority of schools I know will be
itching to get back and get get on with
helping children think that thing can
talk their way through all the issues
that we have here it does feel as if it
has been left up to individual schools
to make it work as best as they can and
I can't help but thinking you know when
it comes to get HS or when it comes to
the economy they've been some incredibly
powerful voices and lobbying groups
speaking out calling for a national
effort in those things and yet in
schools it feels as if things have been
a bit quieter and I just wonder do you
think the government should have done
more and do you think the teaching and
should have done more well we have a
highly developed education system we
give an immense amount of autonomy and
responsibility in individual schools and
to look under under local areas in it in
this country which which in general is
an excellent thing I think what we're
seeing is the importance of melding the
top-down planning that the kinds of
enabling frameworks that governments and
national stakeholders can create and
combined with the the determination the
skill the local knowledge and the create
new things the creativity and enterprise
that you have in the hands of individual
institutions I know that there is so
many people bursting and to take
education forward at the moment let's do
everything we can to make that possible
and then just finally and Sir Michael
Wilshaw who previously did your job and
told me on the show the Ofsted should be
assessing how schools are performing
throughout the lockdown whether it's
online learning or helping disadvantaged
people was been given that millions of
children might not be back in the
classroom until September at the
earliest shouldn't Ofsted be now in
assessing schools to make sure that they
are pulling their way I'm very much like
to have more insight and into into how
schools are approached approaching
the challenge and how well they're doing
but of course they need to be some some
expectations from government we don't
we're doster don't make the standards we
look at how schools are doing against
the standards that government set so I
know that there's some work going on to
get some clear standards and we are
starting to do some survey work in post
16 actually in Fe colleges I'm looking
at how they're teaching and what
learners are getting from it and I very
much want to take that forward and of
course oh excuse me
assuming that we do have substantial
reopening in September and then I very
much expect that we will be we will be
start started starting to get back out
and look at what look at what schools
are doing but very much looking at how
they're coping in the world as it now is
not looking back at what they did in the
summer okay thank you very much for
being on the program today and for
battling through those technical
problems thank you thank you sue